well hello there you're watching the
press preview a first look then at what
is on the front pages
in the next half hour or so we'll see
what's making the headlines with the
political journalist isabel oakshot
and the guardian columnist zoe williams
great to see both of you
lots to talk about so let's uh take a
look at the front pages the metro
starts uh with news that jenny mckee a
nurse who tended to boris johnson
while he was in intensive care with
ronavirus
has resigned from the nhs in protest at
what she feels
the government's is the government's
poor treatment of health service
says for staff according to the mirror
miss mcgee's main objection
is the proposed 1 pay rise for nhs staff
the daily mail reflects confusion over
the new traffic light system
for foreign travel public told to
abandon
summer trips abroad is the headline in
the daily telegraph
the times features the prime minister's
support for tariff
free trade with australia financial
times leads with investors responding
positively to shell's announcement
that it plans to start using greener
fuels to reach the goal of the planet
having net zero carbon emissions by the
year 2050.
the yorkshire post quotes london mayor
sadiq khan insisting he intends the
capital to be
a partner and not a rival in leveling
the north-south
socio-economic divide wall papers still
to come in we will take a look at those
when we get them
but first let's get the thoughts so far
of isabel and zoe
um travel then i guess the focus for
some of the newspapers zoe why don't you
kick off
um the daily mail talking about the
confusion
with it seems travellers still going to
ambulance countries
despite the government intention that
they do not
i think the problem is is that the
confusion is accelerating
not even every day with every hour of
the day so you had some kind of
confusion between what dowden was saying
and what hancock was saying this morning
dowden was saying amber ambulance travel
is fine
matt hancock was saying don't travel
unless you have to now you've got lord
bethel saying
we really should get used to not going
anywhere at all
and probably most people feel whether
they're pro travel or against it whether
they're
really hyper cautious or not they do
feel that maybe the government should
decide these things beforehand and not
be playing them out in public
because it's very embarrassing to watch
and very difficult to make any
sensible judgment over is it unclear
isabel do you think or is it
when we're choosing to interpret it how
we want to
oh well no i think it's completely
unclear i mean it's only
about 10 days since the government
published this
new and long-awaited list of green
amber and red countries and to be clear
at the time they weren't saying that you
can't go to amber countries
this is all to do with the system for
quarantine when you get back
so it is currently legal to travel to
any of the countries on
whatever category they are on the list
but now we've got
different ministers saying different
things and i think we have to
try to identify what it is that the
government is so afraid of here and
clearly
the the main concern is the importing of
new variants
um but there are very very careful
quarantine measures already in place
a hotel quarantine for anyone who
arrives back from a so-called redless
country where
variants of concern have been identified
so i'm really not sure why there's a
sort of sudden
panic in government and it's extremely
unhelpful for people who had thought
that they could legitimately go away and
are now being told actually it's
dangerous and
by the way james bethel the health
minister went a step further and
actually went so far
as to suggest that a creative solution
might be to apply electronic tags to
people coming back from some countries
i mean this is absolutely demented yeah
i mean
that is a fascinating next step
certainly but the daily uh telegraph
certainly picking up on that messaging
from lord bethel
that the problem for many people zoe i
guess is that the idea of a foreign
holiday
even if it's in a couple of months time
is fantastic for their mental well-being
that it is also possibly a driver to get
younger people
to get the vaccine if they think it
might allow them that sort of freedom so
so where do you see the balance do you
think in terms of
the risk of import of whatever it might
be and the need to make everybody feel a
bit better after
in a really difficult few months
i think there are a number of things
going on i think that the indian variant
of concern
is has caused a huge amount of disquiet
because it looks like it might derail
the 21st ending the ending of lockdown
on june the 21st
so you're looking at that and thinking
well this
it would have been much better to put
india on the red list
earlier than the 23rd of april and
now we're dealing with that slowness
just as we've dealt with slowness many
times in the over the past
year and that probably tilts the
government towards being cautious rather
than being
um adventurous because they
they've got a huge amount of accusation
on their backs already that they're not
fast enough
but the truth of it is you need to be
able to disaggregate between
countries that are that are presenting
real
variants of concern and just the
generalized rest of the world because as
you say
it's not just people need a break for
their mental health
people do need you know we we are an
interconnected country people need to
see their families they need to see
they need to see their nearest and
dearest we were never a fortress island
and
many many you know millions of people
have
loved ones that they need to be able to
see so you can't look at the
government's slowness
in designating the indian the indian
variant concern
and then extrapolate from that that
caution
is should be a maximum across every area
but of course that's what
that's what they do do because they're
so aware
that accused of incompetence there's
often some grounds for it
yeah and certainly the mood music from
many is this question of when
india went on the red list isabel the
fact that direct flights from india are
still landing in the uk
and in fact from the testimony of one
passenger we had today
um they are mingling trying to get
through border control
with people coming from other nations
possibly on the green list surely that
needs to be tackled as we
before we get to the dominic coming
story in the in the metro
i mean the logical conclusion of all
this angst about any possible variant
uh that looks different to what we've
already got is that we basically
shut the borders completely and there is
no international travel at all now some
countries
are doing that australia has pretty much
gone down that route and shut its
borders
indefinitely but that would be an
unbelievably drastic decision to take i
mean
the reality is that the coronavirus
mutates that's what viruses
do and there could be a variant of
concern
from pretty much anywhere at any point
and as to your point with
people from redless countries mingling
in the airport i'm not surprised about
that the uh the gates you can't use the
e-gates at heathrow because documents
are being checked and they are woefully
undermanned there so
whilst there is a system in theory to
segregate
red list arrivals in practice they've
all been on the same aeroplanes together
anyway
so rather what's the point particularly
since everybody who's got on the plane
has a negative pcr test anyway
yeah i mean that that is one good news
part of it isn't it so let's go to the
metro then dominic
cummings has threatened to release the
only copy of a crucial document
allegedly detailing how boris johnson's
lockdown and vaccine decisions
led to catastrophe dot dot dot tell us
more zoe well
i mean we should say to begin with that
number 10 does deny that any
any such document exists so it's it's
hard at the moment to see how
how they really kind of bottom out which
bit is true and which bit isn't
definitely
cummings is on a kamikaze mission to
carry this fight on for as long as the
fight will go
and you know he's starting to come
before innumerable committees
and release innumerable things he's
basically saying i know where the bodies
are buried
and furthermore i'm prepared to tell
everybody
the problem i think is it was sort of
flagged by
his twitter thread earlier today when
he'd talked at great length about
what we know works about lockdowns and
what we know doesn't work about
lockdowns
people do look at him as somebody who
doesn't take any notice of rules and has
no respect for others so
it's really he's sort of casting himself
as this kind of sword of truth
and people think of him as a chancer so
i wonder
whether there isn't some wiggle room in
that
even if he does come out with things
which are quite stark for the government
and even if
people are inclined to believe them and
think the less of the government on the
basis of them
i think they'll have some within wiggle
room just in the very low standing that
cummings himself has
among both you know voters and
commentators yeah it is quite stark to
say the coveted plan
was supposed to be world class but
turned out to be part disaster
part non-existent i mean it's pretty
tough language isn't it
and if you reflect on that isabel and uh
in the in the final minutes of this part
of the show
move on to what is it across many of the
newspapers which is the nurse that
uh nursed boris johnson when he had
covid has decided to quit
i mean this is such an obvious political
misstep by the
government here and well done to the
papers that have kept tabs on those that
looked after boris johnson
i i always thought it was extraordinary
that the government offered only a one
percent pay rise
not necessarily because nurses should be
more deserving than many other
categories of people who've worked
really hard during the pandemic but just
because politically
the optics of it are disastrous it was
always going to backfire
i thought they would have done a u-turn
by now but they've stood firm
i doubt this nurse is going to make much
difference but it's really really
bad look for the government yes and to
give them their due i think this is her
speaking to a channel 4 documentary
but she's off to work in the caribbean
so she might have gone anyway because
that sounds quite tempting
before heading back to new zealand too
zoey
well i mean i i'm not sure i agree with
that i mean you're talking we're talking
about somebody who's obviously quite a
committed
public servant obviously you know takes
the job very seriously and takes the
takes her level of care very seriously
so i don't i don't know if we can say
well she would have gone to the
caribbean anyway because the weather is
better even though we can certainly say
that the weather will be better
the point is it's vanishingly rare
for nhs staff to make a political point
like this
it's really really rare i mean you get
it from
a very few outliers and normally
extremely senior ones you don't get it
from people who
you know think to pick up their career
again with the nhs later
or need the references or have a kind of
very strong sense of their public duty
quite separate from the politics of the
government
um so i think it's it's a canary in the
coal mine
moment you know she is an important
story because she didn't ask boris
johnson personally
but i think she probably is indicative
of a huge number of nurses who
feel completely undervalued and
overworked and overstretched and burnt
out
and so even though i agree with isabel
that the optics are terrible
i think the underlying problem that the
nhs is going to end up really at
breaking point
if only because the people won't work
for it anymore
are actually worse in the long run zoe
isabel we will see you in just a moment
plenty more still to come including how
to tackle the north-south divide mayor
of london has some ideas
talking about that in just a minute well
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me now isabel oakshot and
zoe williams welcome back to both of you
um zoe let's go to the yorkshire post
shall we london's mayor pledges to help
heal the
north-south rift how is he planning to
do that
i think at the moment he's it is mainly
rhetorical you know he's saying
we've been pitched against each other as
competitors for
so long and it's actually not helping
anybody and
london is going through a lot of the
same things that northern towns and
northern cities are going through
and we don't need to the idea that i'm
a liberal elite and you're a red wall is
completely absurd we're going through
exactly the same pressures and the same
constraints
and i and i really welcome this because
this should have been way more fanfare
about
the the bit of may the sixth which
wasn't a disaster for labour which was
essentially
andy burnham sadiq khan mark drakeford
you know these these people making
very similar cases in geographically
quite different places
and saying you know we've all we've all
got the same problems we've all got the
same problems with housing with wages
with rents
the problems might not be identical but
they are enough to build a base around
and all the direction of travel over the
past five
even 10 years has been these areas are
left behind and these areas are elites
and they'll never understand each other
and i think what sadiq's trying to do is
say
actually we understand each other pretty
well
and actually that takes us straight to
the guardian doesn't it which talks
about
chronic underfunding in local government
plus the social care
issues of neglect this is the national
audit office and has all been exposed
decades-long weaknesses by coronavirus
what's the
what's the guardian saying isabel
well the uh the coronavirus has exposed
all sorts of weaknesses and i think it's
bewildering really that sadiq khan is
going on about this his job is to be
mayor of london not heal north
north-south divides and
more divisions are going to be exposed
if the government goes down the route of
local lockdowns which is what they've
been talking about
and zoe mentioned andy burnham the very
very effective mayor of manchester he's
already made it clear tonight
that the the parts of the north will
resist very heavily
uh local lockdowns that would certainly
exacerbate
north-south divide so i think there are
huge challenges here absolutely
and you know the guardian touches on
some of this stuff but it seems
uh strange indeed for the mayor of
london to be focusing on that right now
yes i'm not surprising they're resisting
um the uh the bolton and p
mark logan conservative saying today
that bolton had only been out of
restrictions
for three and a half weeks in total in
the whole time since the start of the
pandemic and that was last july so
it's hard it's hard work isn't it so
isabel we'll we'll look forward to
seeing you at half eleven thank
thank
you